anybody else with kids in here you just  his family how old are your kids  for you boys or girls what the [ __ ] was  that noise  what was that noise  can you make it again okay  wait so you you said your 14 year old  was what  boy his homecoming dance tonight  oh he's so he's [ __ ] on your bed huh  i can't i can't believe homecoming and  you're letting them go back to your  house to [ __ ] on your bed that is crazy  oh put your fingers in your ears that's  not where his fingers are going to be  [Applause]  but  is that where you're on the phone caller  don't you [ __ ] in my bed don't you [ __ ]  at my bed  that's when he was like i gotta take  this call  oh he has no game sure okay uh  no no no no no yeah yeah yeah of course  he's not  [Music]  [Music]  you